[Musique]
du
bon voilà réunion bonjour le monde
comment ils et les amis est-ce que vous
allez bien oui vous avez bien manger
bien bien sûr messieurs dames les comme
ça dans la vie
aujourd'hui où s'annulent et nous les en
face de l'aéroport roland garros au
moufia exactement et on va voir gérard
et emmanuel qui vont nous faire visiter
leur atelier de bijouterie messieurs
dames de la bijouterie pour vous
aujourd'hui
oui oui venez venez en plus avec quoi de
la lave ou mailles larges volcan et
bijoux avec biarrote bien bien bien bien
en plus mauvais temps la mauvais temps
il va pleuvoir la vie rien n'est rien
[Musique]
nous voilà dans l'antre de la tresse
comment il élira ça va bien emmanuel ont
chanté la couleur alors on commence par
kid on va commencer par emmanuel
emmanuel nollet dans un atelier de
création 800 me sens les muses part à
tous il traîne 90 côté 12 du mois
wayne rooney s'il te plaît donc là on
est à l'atelier de la bijouterie et
toutes nos créations passe par ici
nestea et après elles ont à la
bijouterie
mais où en gros ce coffret ici et comme
on arrive là en fait la pointe comme une
encore on apprend en apprentissage mais
apprendre quoi pas encore je n'ai pas
encore en train de créer mon rôle pour
l'instant c'est de fabriquer mais je me
donne un coup de main ils ont encore
offert et amy séné fait au mieux pour
l'instant parce que là mais apprendre
encore ouais entre nous est-ce que
rivière de méchants bien ça va voyez
très méchant versement des travail et
les possibilités de donana de la ligue 1
ne trahi les métaux précieux et d'autres
métaux non précieux aussi argentée le
cuir le bon mot et ensuite m'a vraiment
voulu donner une touche réunion à nos
créations en apportant l'appoint
travaillant la pierre de lave fabrique
des perles des colliers
et en pièces beaucoup plus massif ça
c'était larceveau convient donc elle lui
donne une autre partie de l'atelier
mais vous le montrez moi la matière
brute première donc monter un petit peu
donc ça c'est nos communes du trégor
voilà donc la na la matière bois lalala
règne arrive c est ce qu en allemagne
est choisi et le dal et wiba prix dépend
de la création que nous veut faire les
français annonce à ceux ci aussi mais là
aussi c'est aussi vrai nom ça ouais bah
ouais c'est la roche main et ado je
serai pas tous avec toi
[Musique]
et dis moi où astiz est fournie à zot
donc fabrique des carrières de gardien
de l'île
d'accord on a écrit à deux partout ben
une sainte marie et une autre sur
l'étang salé alors emmanuel maintenant
tu va m'apprendre à moi aussi à tailler
la pierre c'est seulement tailler la
pierre d'angle
c'est une succession de machines qui est
qui va nous aider à obtenir cst femme
espère d'accord mais tu n'as pas peur
que de la concurrence a sûrement japon
très vite nous là non j'adore aller vite
après toute façon la concurrence
l'opérateur mais c'est l'innovation qui
compte c'est clair la belle pièce
exactement alors on commence vas-y donc
ici c'est là c'est la laci pour faire
les cubes de petits cubes d'accord donc
là je je je prends un pavé comme ça
quand je fais une lamelle et après je
négocie chacune alors qu offertes et
après une passe de l'autre côté
eh bien on va passer de la structure va
voir ça voilà et s'il n'a différentes
étapes donc la marée noire des
différentes étapes du cube on a le cube
là comme ailleurs une des grosses in car
sinon d'accord
comment la réaliserons bhr1
et au fur et à mesure pour les jeunes
ingénieurs m'ont dit d'accord jusqu'à ce
qu'ils arrivent comme ça voilà voilà
la lutte pour la paix elle macpherson en
marche
ouais ok ok ok on l'a fait mais d'aller
gagner parfois ouais ouais en fait de
soul assez creux voilà
[Musique]
donc emmanuel tu me disais que tu paies
à celle là fait elle avec la même
machine vous allez à la petite machine
qui sert à pons et bien on changera
corinne georges fauré bon et donc
regardez moi sommes messieurs dames
une fois enfilé commencé joly est ce que
vous leur besoin de revenir ici est
reponsable pour l'année en cours jolie
ou avec cette machine là bas l'une a
rendu déjà souvent quand on a quelques
petites retouches à faire à la fin oui
voilà voilà le gros est fait avec la
machine mais quelques petites retouches
à faire des choix simples un bracelet
qui ont associé des personnes précieuse
ici l'améthyste d'accord il parie que
ton papa une une autre manière de
travailler
tout ça m'a fait chier nous savons
aliments alors gérard arnoux les dans
l'atelier toujours des c'est lui le
grand manitou de grands chefs celui par
qui tout a commencé on va dire c'est
vrai la commenter sa grande joie quand
j'ai commencé en 85 avec vraiment rien
rien avec un bras c'est que ma mère
avait là on a commencé à travailler avec
ça et ça a commencé comme ça lui nous a
montré un petit peu comment comment
on travaillait cette pierre mais toi tu
as une technique particulière c'est vrai
au niveau de la cave à la pierre
volcanique il ya plusieurs types de
l'avant l'appareil faisant ce que je
vais vous falloir c'est surtout le type
de l'âge qu'on appelle l'appliquer en
fait tu me parlais de sa saison là
effectivement voilà c'est une saisine
pièce il ya semi finis ces coins les
plus petits un tribunal on lire en p -o
le bus était trouvé une technique vous
faire tenir le métal à l'intérieur
d'accord est ce que c'est une technique
que si vous la trouvez
est-ce que vous la base aussi la
technique c'est une technique qu'ils
aient tour effectivement voilà en
exclusivité mondiale messieurs dames
gerra et samantha non la technique parce
que ça se sent ça donc ça veut dire que
ça c'est technique la réunion voir un
aussi une sorte d'al bus de la
bijouterie ben oui bah oui elle montre
massa serait mieux voir
alors donc là je rends en fait c'est de
la poudre d'argent je fais tu récupères
en fait de dédommagement une fois que
j'ai travaillé il fait que en faveur de
dix maisons basques ont récupéré dans
l'anonymat y voilà on précise que la
peau en fait c'est une cuillère qu'on
met sous la table comme ça pour
récupérer un peu les déchets en dieu
mais c'est fait sauf que là les déchets
c'est de l'or et de l'argent
robben donc c'est pas trop déchets quand
même hein et de l'avancée de l'argent
c'est du guide tout simplement tu vois
que le métal il faut très bien on va
récupérer
maïla on va passer dans cet état c'est
la fonte du métal mettre nos placements
je me disais en fait il faut laisser
sécher des arts effectivement il faut il
faut laisser ces gens n'ont pas
diversément 10 10 à 15 minutes ils
disent on va et entre temps comme j'ai
préparé c'est la voix la voix
s'addressent qu'ils sont terrifiés
voilà c'est une patate il en donne ça il
faut sécher ou donc la super on va aller
à la fin du match
[Musique]
donc là c'est en fait je n'ai pas pu
demeurer pendant les 100 plus grands
enjeux est souple et rational et c est
par rapport à la machine
ok alors commença déjà bien voir
l'argent et l'envoie encore mieux alors
donc géré à une fois que ça est terminé
que les gens comprennent bien la route
tout le travail que tu vois pas ça comme
ça tu vois je vois le travail et mais
sur d'autres pièces là l'idée par
exemple c'était surtout parlé de daqui
d'incruster satan dubois le bal
endémiques de la réunion bas tamarins de
l'ajuster c'est le truc ça et après on
peut les sortir après qu'a pu être dont
on en voudrait il s'appelle ça peut être
saulnier de cogner et c'est sans poisson
local
[Musique]
selon gérard novasen aux ateliers
on va descendre beaucoup plus bas et
nous les a dans sa bijouterie il a livré
10 mois est ce que on a pas mal de
jeunes qui veut faire formateur ou pas
ou c'est un métier en devenir ou c ou
trouve que imerys un peu plus de lumière
qui a personne par exemple lycée il fait
les créations en a toujours
la théorie du boult aux bois pas
consécutivement à un rapport qui fait
que l'accueil de la vente de notre sueur
a fait des heureux
en fin de nuit d'hier est là parce que
95 %
c'est l'écrivain nos créations gérard et
l'usom palin est momentanément c'est que
on a quand même une technique
particulière qu elle a inventé pour
incruster le métal dans la roche déjà et
hocine à l'originalité de dire tiens je
vais tester un bijou avec de la pierre
d'un atelier malhabile et de tous les
jours you légion en train de faire
autant tester atteignent créer la même
opération il ne va pas non là aux
confins création l'art une création
année par année et on ne peut pas mais
voit son sourire ça c'est un beau
guillem travail là où m levé pour ce
travail le matin ça se voit le plus
aisément parce qu'en fin de compte
client quand on voit effectivement les
gens mécontents
ce trophée les potes les créations qu'on
fait un axe est gracieuse et des choses
magnifiques prévenu mes coups de me
remercier
mais si on craque et puis 20 millions à
la prochaine et je vais revenir
promis juré tu reviendras toi hein on
verra ensemble à cordes super salue
gérard qu'elle estime à la prochaine
[Musique]
tout